so I've used one piece here one half of
this the horizontal part now i'm going
to use the vertical part okay so i'm
going to name therefore at the same time
I know what the y-value is right so I'm
going to bring that straight into this
equation on the same age that's the
vertical component equals V times the
time and down this time Omega thing
which I have here d on V cos then times
so theta just I'm just substituting in
at the moment haven't done a simplified
whatsoever okay take away 5 watts off
the same time dr v cos theta all squared
ok that's edge now I'll do a tiny tiny
bit of tidying up here right it looks
like I've got I'm going to lose the v's
on this side over here so I'm just going
to get d sine-theta on cos theta how
does that look yeah I just cancelled up
take away 5 d square on v square cos
square theta how's it looking happy yeah
now just looking at this you need to
pause for above it okay to see whether
you are on the right track or not this
is the thing if they're always with with
identities right now there are lots of
good signals that I'm on the right track
have a look at the result that was given
and have a look at this line okay now
the first thing I notice is it's very
tempting to put the site theater and the
COS theta together and write tan theta
because that's clearly simpler right but
i'm not going to salt want to suggest to
me why there's no Ted veto the result of
trying to prove right in fact what I do
have is the sines and cosines separate
which suggests to me but from this line
I'm going to have to like multiply
through or device or something like that
they're going to end up separate anyway
so no point could buy you together at
this point so I've got sine theta and
cos theta which I in this result that's
good what else is in this result that I
was in here okay I've got a 5d there so
that's good I wanted that what else I've
got the cos square and
and lastly for things that I want I've
got v square that's kind of important
because that's clearly the subject of
this equation ok so it's nestled all the
way down in that denominator but I can
get there that's fine fire at the same
time as vertice all these good things
about it right all these things I want I
also notice I'm missing something and
I've got something that I don't need so
I'm missing a tan alpha in fact there
are no alphas here and I've got
something which i'm not meant to have
namely ok so well actually the two
things there for a few Tori but that way
I've got a d squared here there's no d
square here but more significantly I
have an H like at least I have the the
brighter or their right so he can be
fine but this age shouldn't be here at
all right this somehow has got to get
out of the way right ah so when you put
these two piece of fish together what
you missy and this extra thing that
you've got together clearly bit this
can't be a coincidence right so you
think well what's the relationship
what's the relationship between the
thing you've got and the thing you try
to get turn off ok very good so if you
want to just briefly sketch the critical
part of the diagram on your own piece of
paper right obviously you don't need to
draw out the whole thing with the
basketball so on but alpha is down here
if the angle up to the hoop right so
you've got the height there and the
distance horizontally to the hoop so
clearly you can see where turn off is
it's hid doesn't that make sense which
therefore suggests to me what am I going
to do from this next line i'm going to
divide everything through by deep ok
that will give me hie which is tan alpha
that will give it to me on the left hand
side so I'm going to bite through H all
of d equals
get in morning so let's pause that you
know sometimes I I'm showing your proof
and you're like but how did how many
would think to do step ex-rights like
you know you add and subtract the same
thing or you / something inside but why
did why would you do that like the H is
just fine they're over on the left-hand
side the answer is well actually he's
not by looking carefully what you've got
where you've gotta go that's what kind
of gives you signals that I need to do
something that's not necessarily obvious
so I can get the pieces are born I'm
pretty much there is that was the
hardest part of Part B Part 1 okay I've
got to substitute you through this
left-hand side as 10 haha and then all
that's really left at this point is to
make V squared the subject so I just
need to be careful than ship things
around or lack of thing what would you
like me to do okay I could go for coins
alone at first but I think it might be
even more advantageous to me to get rid
of as many fractions as I care because
notice see that tan alpha in the result
of try to prove do you notice he's
actually part of a product right so
being that it's going to get attached to
a close square theater at a second I
might as well just do it now because
that will get rid of some stuff over the
right-hand side so if i multiply through
which by the way is equivalent
essentially together commented on video
i'm going to get cos squared turn over
here what's going to happen to this
chair there it'll be sine theta cos
theta or in the order they're giving us
so cos need us okay hey there you go
okay now what you get left mean over
here you is that ok so it looks to me
like to get the denominator my what here
or I need to swap these guys from left
to right does that make sense so I'm
going to put 5d on the square did you
see where I'm going down good take a
reciprocal to second and this gets me on
the right hand side that very
intimidated to go do that I
before there it is right there and then
pretty much home aight aight i'll just
take your supra course and the last
thing i need to do is multiply does that
make sense yeah so I better get my I
might even go to write down there's the
result of already got it okay how are
you feeling about that three bucks worth
of work right so that was not easy to
access they feel if you like whoa really
okay that's a hard plot to get to this
question which is why the mean marks for
the rest of this the rest of the parts
were so low because some people didn't
even get over this bar I used it right
here here so make sense so I used this
equation in order have it expression for
time which I could the particular time
when I go through the hood so that I
could pop it into my wife waited so
that's it so I use this first I used it
first because it was simpler right I can
make tea the subject very easily here
whereas here it's a bit of a disaster
that I can see it's gonna get squared
out that's what my second okay very good